[Music]
christopher is with us he is in saint
cloud minnesota hi christopher how are
you
i'm doing pretty good see um i'll just
start with my question first considering
my situation should i buy a house now
with that being said my current
situation i'm currently a nurse a new
nurse that i graduated with my
associate's degree this past spring
and i'm also a student pushing my rn to
bsn and i'm also a landlord um and so
i'm kind of like you know with all these
things at play you know we're working
part-time
and in my situation should i buy a house
and i know that's not a whole ton of
information but that's okay i got you so
so you're you're how old i'm 22. and you
make how much money
uh gross right now being part-time it's
about 36 100.
okay
so you're finishing up school right now
correct yep i'm doing the r in the bs
sense i'm currently a registered nurse
but it's a wonderful career path
um now i would concentrate on that i
don't want you to get distracted
i want you to finish school
sure so do that how are you a landlord
well i bought a house with my brother in
2018 and we've rented it out ever since
and it's all paid for
so you were 18 years old
correct
we bought it for well a little
background i used to do construction
before nursing and so we bought a house
that was like 31 000 fixed it up and
then rented it out and then
what would it sell for
probably right now 110 in being in that
location
okay
if you didn't own it would you buy it
right now
um
no probably not won't y'all sell it
uh because we're renting it right now i
guess
it's a single family
yeah single family home so when's the
lease up
uh it would be i think in december if i
remember correctly okay
i would consider putting that house on
the market after the first year and
getting rid of it here's the thing i
don't think that house
although it was a neat experiment for
you and experience to do that at 18
years old i don't think that house is
the secret sauce to your future nor is
home ownership at 22 the secret sauce to
your future i think the secret sauce to
your future is you
finishing this
nursing path that you are on you are
going to have tremendous opportunity to
make a lot of money and uh stay steadily
employed the rest of your life as long
as you want to be a nurse i mean this is
an incredible feel there's such a
shortage and ken the upside's really
strong there's a lot of upside for you
uh as a nurse even if you want to go
beyond that after a while and i would
agree with dave here the houses are
still going to be there you're 22
you've got this investment property that
you could absolutely sell take your
portion of the profit and that becomes a
part of your down payment but i wouldn't
be in any kind of rush i'd get through
school let's get in nursing let's get
settled let's get our sights on where we
want to go within nursing what that
mountain top looks like the houses will
be there sometimes christopher people
miss achieving a major goal in their
life not because the goal was hard but
because they got distracted and added
too many other things on their plate
and that and home ownership and
landlording and all that other crap
while you're just trying to get through
school i'm trying to clean up your plate
and just say focus on what really
matters what the real goal is and these
other things could just be devilish
distractions